[Applaudissements]
le gars au départ ils vont mettre dans
ta quête j'ai fait hier
et là ils le sont pas il en met deux du
coup il s'en tire est pas il en met une
puis retenta 2 alors que n'a pas réussi
hier je devais arriver bizarrement il
faut montrer ça à juillet tout ce qu'ils
voient donne alors c'est lui il en pense
quoi votre frère c'est très simple on
arrête des gens dans la rue on leur pose
des questions une question peu importe
landa et pendant qu'ils nous répondrons
va vite dans un camion qui a coté
changer s'habiller à peu près comme ça
vaut le déguisement d'avant à peu près à
1 comme eux n'avaient pas le reconnaître
vous julie vous c'est moi chaque fois et
c'est le ils en pensent quoi votre frère
nouvel épisode c'est parti quelle pièce
de l'osm et ross schnell paris cela nous
paraissait sommet one sont méfiantes et
manosque et bien c'est ce dont la
guitare la basse ou vers paris latino
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens madame parisien a lâché
pris le bus pour venir de la gare de
lyon et j'ai trouvé super super pas de
problème votre soeur elle en pense quoi
pareil regardez c'est trop son prénom
âge mais vis de lui dire il s'appelle
philippe par philous autant brasse je
pars avec elle on va se les shows vidéo
bon allez transports en commun parisiens
fonctionnent quand même plutôt bien vous
je dirais même très bien et votre frère
ils en pensent quoi faire
assange était quoi et tout doux mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens très pratique et
très rapide est votre seul en pense quoi
pratique et rapide pour donner deux
heures non plus quoi on échange là c'est
plutôt pratique ça sert pas mal puisque
vu que c'est assez bouché
ici ça nous aide pas mal surtout quand
c'est gratuit
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent ton frère
bien tu as vu ton soit la black star i
go c'est pourquoi tout ça va bien vite
et plus tard en plus je te cherche un
loto est pas là moi j'étais pas là mais
pas l'arrêter ou à la la la la la la
c'est pas la traiter ou voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]